“Have we tried starving it of oxygen?”
Verheiden asked, sounding bored with the conversation
already.
“Yes, we have,” Doctor Kelley grumbled
in reply.
“We were able to create a vacuum, removed
99% of the air from its containment chamber,
and its life signs dropped.”
“I’m sensing there’s a ‘but’ coming
next,” the Research Assistant sighed, rolling
his eyes.
“Typical.”
“But 682 was able to fill the chamber with
a gas mixture of ozone, chlorine, xenon and…
Oh, I forget,” the Foundation doctor answered,
getting more and more agitated.
“Point is, it was able to form and expel
chemicals even without any active life signs.”
“Huh, it’s almost like there’s a reason
we call it the ‘Hard to Destroy Reptile’,
I just wish I could figure out what it was,”
Verheiden retorted, making no attempt to mask
his sarcasm, giving a dry chuckle, much to
Doctor Kelley’s annoyance.
It was a debate that had been going on for
what felt like the entire history of the SCP
Foundation: how could anyone possibly kill
SCP-682?
The creature had long been one of the most
infamous anomalies that the Foundation had
ever encountered, so much so that the Hard
to Destroy Reptile was synonymous with the
organization.
But the mandate still stood that it needed
to be destroyed, as soon as someone was able
to figure out a way.
Although they hadn’t quite exhausted every
possible option just yet, most of the researchers
were running short on ideas; thinking up a
plan to kill 682 was made all the harder knowing
the creature had survived and regenerated
from every single previous test.
If there were something, some neutralization
method that was going work, surely they would
have found it by now.
“Maybe we should just leave it?”
Research Assistant Verheiden shrugged.
“I mean, we’ve got it sitting in a tank
of acid, perpetually melting it as fast as
it can reconstitute its body.
While it’s like that, 682’s hardly a threat
to anyone.”
“Hardly a threat?”
Doctor Kelley scoffed, clearly more than perturbed.
“You’re dead wrong, Verheiden, as long
as that monstrosity continues to live, it
poses a constant threat to every single human
being on this planet.
Hell, every lifeform in the world, it hates
everything else that much.”
“Look, I’m just saying that, after Rees
and Foster were discussing this issue and
the whole…”
his voice trailed off for a moment.
“After the ‘situation’ that led to,
maybe it’s better if we leave 682 alone.
It seems that every time we try to come up
with a solution to our ‘Reptile Problem’,
something always goes wrong.
The whole thing’s cursed, doc.
Like a big joke where the punchline is more
and more of us end up dead while 682 keeps
on living just to spite us.”
“You have no idea what you’re talking
about!”
Kelley yelled, infuriated by such a suggestion
that trying to destroy SCP-682 once and for
all was little more than an exercise in futility.
“Hey, hey, take it easy!”
his subordinate replied, trying to calm Kelley
down.
“You gotta admit, doc, it seems more impossible
than…
well, all the other impossible things we see
in this job.”
“It’s an important mission of the SCP
Foundation, Verheiden,” the doctor growled,
holding back his rage.
“To safeguard humanity from anomalous threats.
I’m convinced we just need to find the right
set of variables, the right conditions or
equipment, and I… we can kill this thing
once and for all.”
“But where do we go from here?
I mean, we’ve tried conventional weapons,
other anomalies.
If other powerful SCPs can’t kill this thing,
what chance do we have?”
“Maybe it’s a case of finding the right
one,” Doctor Kelley theorized.
“SCP-738 and SCP-743 both failed, we couldn’t
even fit 682 in the booths of the Clockworks
if we wanted to.
So, back to the drawing board: what haven’t
we tried?”
“Heh, why don’t we just throw SCP-035
on it?”
Verheiden remarked, clearly making another
snide, sarcastic joke.
“Darn thing wouldn’t even fit over SCP-682’s
big lizard snout, would probably just slide
off onto the floor.”
“Hold on,” Kelley replied, pondering the
idea for a moment.
Since being assigned to the site containing
SCP-682, studying the Reptile up close, he
had become determined to figure out some way
to finally kill it.
It would make him a legend in the history
of the Foundation, being the one who did what
they had failed to do for so many years.
“That might just work!”
“Doc, I was kidding.
Doc?”
his Research Assistant replied, turning to
see that Doctor Kelley was already racing
down the corridors of the facility.
***
“That’s an absurd suggestion,” Doctor
Bright answered when Kelley came rushing up
to him, hastily explaining his plan for SCP-682’s
termination.
“No, listen here Jack, please just hear
me out,” Kelley urged.
“Yes, SCP-035 is a dangerous anomaly in
its own right, but it’s also deadly to the
wearer.
It secretes that substance that corrodes the
body of whoever, or whatever wears it, right?”
“And you came up with the idea to place
such an object over the head of a creature
that can regenerate and adapt to almost all
forms of damage?”
Bright retorted before the other Foundation
doctor could finish.
“That’s precisely my proposal!” he replied.
“Look, we already keep SCP-682 contained
in a vat of acid for safety, right?
Melt away at its body before it has a chance
to fully regenerate, keeping it in this perpetual
state of healing and sustaining damage at
the same speed.
What if we go the whole hog, let SCP-035 take
control of the Reptile until the mask drenches
it in black goo, melting it down for good?”
“And you’ve considered the other possibilities?”
Bright asked, trying his best to walk away
from Kelley as they spoke.
“That SCP-035 takes full control of 682
and is granted an immortal host that might
not degrade under its secretion?
There’s a far higher likelihood that SCP-035
wouldn’t even fit on the Reptile.
Its face is the wrong shape.
The Possessive Mask is made for humanoid faces,
not reptilian ones.”
“Yes, but the Reptile is able to adapt,
is it not?”
Kelley fired back.
“Correct, and if we allowed it to adapt
to SCP-035, we could have an even greater
monstrosity on our hands, a hybrid of the
Possessive Mask and the Hard to Destroy Reptile,”
Jack Bright shouted, fed up with having to
listen to Kelley’s outlandish idea.
“A being like that would be hell-bent on
destruction.I’m sorry, Doctor Kelley, but
the answer is no.”
“Please,” the other doctor begged.
“Just send it up the chain on my behalf,
I just need clearance to run one test.”
“I can take it higher, but I’m telling
you now, the answer won’t change,” Doctor
Bright admitted, agreeing just to get Kelley
to back off.
Sure enough, later the very same day Doctor
Kelley received a notice from the senior research
staff, his superiors within the Foundation.
“Doctor Kelley, we have learned of your
proposed experiment for terminating SCP-682.
Unfortunately, after conferring, we have decided
this course of action would pose too great
a risk to the safety of civilians as well
as our own staff here at the SCP Foundation.
Additionally, Doctor Bright has raised concerns
with us about your recent obsessive behavior.
We would kindly ask you to attend a mandatory
psychiatric evaluation tomorrow at 1500 hours,
to assess and potentially reassign you.
Given your interest in using SCP-035, we feel,
in your current state, you may be at risk
of being influenced by the Psionic effects
of the Possessive Mask.”
The message from the research supervisors
was still open on Kelley’s computer terminal
when Verheiden went to check on him.
It looked like the doctor had started typing
a response:
“You idiots want to psych eval me?
You want to ignore the actual present threat
to the Foundation?
The longer we keep that Reptile alive, the
more everyone and everything is at risk.
But you want to persecute me for trying to
come up with a radical solution?
If you’re all too cowardly to act, then
I have no choice but to-”
Kelley had left the rest unfinished without
hitting ‘Send’.
Although it didn’t take much of a reach
for his Research Assistant to realize that
his sentence would’ve ended with ‘do it
myself’.
His heart pounding, regretting ever suggesting
using the Possessive Mask as a joke, Verheiden
got up and ran, racing through the corridors
as fast as he could towards the containment
cell for SCP-035.
He had a sick feeling in his stomach that
he might find Doctor Kelley already there.
Acting out of a fit of uncontrollable anger
and what he thought was a moral obligation
to destroy SCP-682, Doctor Kelley had stolen
some amnestics from the Foundation’s storerooms.
Lacing two cups of coffee with the memory-altering
drugs, he’d offered the hot beverages to
the pair of armed guards stationed outside
the room where SCP-035 was held.
Accepting what they thought to be an act of
kindness from a Foundation doctor, both security
officers had quickly forgotten why they were
standing around so idly.
Luckily, the friendly Foundation doctor had
reminded them they had reached the end of
their shift and were free to go and punch
the clock.
With no reason to question him, the guards
wandered away, leaving Doctor Kelley alone
with SCP-035.
Then, the whispers started.
They seemed garbled, unintelligible at first,
but the closer that Doctor Kelley drew to
the glass case, the clearer the voice of the
Possessive Mask started to sound.
“So,” it hissed.
“I hear you have a Reptile problem, Doctor.”
***
The loud wailing of alarms told Verheiden
he was already too late: SCP-035 had breached
containment, thanks to a rogue Doctor Kelley,
no doubt.
The Research Assistant cursed his own big
mouth for even mentioning SCP-035 as an option
for destroying the Reptile.
Although, he could never have known Kelley
would take it so seriously as a suggestion.
But now the doctor’s obsession with being
responsible for finally ending SCP-682 was
running rampant.
Turning a corner, the Research Assistant stopped
in his tracks; he had quickly realized it
was pointless heading towards the SCP-035
containment chamber – Doctor Kelley would
already have what he needed from there.
But there was only one place he’d be heading
once he had the Possessive Mask in tow.
Taking the corresponding corridor, Verheiden
raced through the Foundation facility towards
the direction of the room housing the vat
of acid where the Hard to Destroy Reptile
was waiting.
A trail of bodies scalded and scorched with
a viscous black substance told him he was
on the right track.
It was the same corrosive secretion that leaked
from the Possessive Mask, meaning that either
Kelley had forced someone to wear it… or
worse, had been manipulated into putting it
on himself.
If SCP-035 had convinced him it might have
the answer to killing the Reptile, then little
could have stopped Doctor Kelley from bringing
it to SCP-682, whom the mask could use as
its next host.
And, to Researcher Verheiden’s horror, it
looked like exactly that was about to happen
as he arrived in SCP-682’s containment cell.
“Doc, stop!” he yelled in desperation.
“This has gone too far, please!”
Doctor Kelley turned to look over at his assistant,
his face now obscured by the carved, exaggerated
porcelain grin of the Possessive Mask.
Its smile was one of twisted glee, like it
was taunting Verheiden for even trying to
stop it.
The corrosive liquid was leaking out from
underneath it, spilling down Doctor Kelley’s
bare neck and onto his shoulders, rapidly
melting away everything it touched.
Meanwhile, the acid from SCP-682’s tank
was starting to be drained away, and the monster
within was beginning to stir.
Hooking two fingers under the edge of the
porcelain comedy mask, Kelley started to wrench
it off his face, compelled by SCP-035.
The mask knew of the Foundation doctor’s
plan, and was far less interested in helping
kill 682 as it was using the Reptile as an
immortal host, finally one that wouldn’t
degrade in the same way so many others had
before.
With the last of his strength, he pulled the
mask away, his brain-dead body succumbing
to its injuries and dropping the mask… right
into SCP-682’s tank.
As SCP-035 landed on the creature’s head,
it let out a wild, pained roar.
Black streaks of corrosive secretion began
to trail down the Reptile, making it thrash
at the pain of the substance burning and dissolving
the outer layers of its thick hide.
The noises let out by 682 were enough to pull
Verheiden’s eyes away from Doctor Kelley,
whose body had collapsed lifelessly.
He had died trying to bring an end to a monster
the Foundation had never successfully destroyed,
yet another life lost in the pursuit of killing
the unkillable Reptile.
As the life-hating lizard thrashed about,
looking like it was about to burst free of
its cage in a rage, the Research Assistant
shot across the room to reverse the acid draining
from the tank.
The Foundation’s security team arrived in
the containment room just as the acid tank
had very nearly been fully refilled.
Although he had no idea if it would have an
effect, Verheidedn had stopped it just short
of also submerging the Possessive Mask in
the acid too, which still seemed to be precariously
balanced on SCP-682’s head, not covering
its face.
As a cleaning crew arrived to remove Kelley
and the bodies he’d left in his wake, the
Foundation had to come up with a plan for
removing SCP-035 without their staff falling
into the acid vat.
“No, no, hold on,” Verheiden insisted.
“I know this started as just a joke between
the Doc and me, and I had no idea he had taken
it so seriously but… look.”
He pointed to the inside of the tank.
The gigantic reptilian monster was completely
still, while the Possessive Mask still let
streaks of its corrosive substance drip over
its head.
And it looked to be taking effect, still dissolving
every part of the Reptile it came into contact
with.
“Maybe…
it could work?” the Research Assistant mused.
“Retreat to a safe zone,” the security
chief instructed.
“We are to await orders on a further course
of action.
If you wanna observe, you’ll have to do
it from a distance.”
Falling back, it seemed the entire Foundation
was waiting with bated breath to see what
would happen next.
Through back-and-forth radio chatter with
their superiors, neither Verheiden nor the
security forces seemed to know how to proceed.
From the outside, it looked like SCP-682 and
SCP-035 were at a stalemate.
But in the back of their minds, everyone had
to wonder: how long was this going to last?
What nobody had noticed, however, was the
unique way in which SCP-682 had adapted to
coming into contact with SCP-035.
A lump had formed on the topmost part of the
Reptile’s head, its scales had parted, allowing
for the fleshy growth to swell until it was
roughly the size and shape of the average
human face.
It lacked any of the usual characteristics
– no eyes, nose, or mouth – but seemed
to work as a way to better mount the Possessive
Mask, since it couldn’t fit over the Hard
to Destroy Reptile’s long, lizard-like features.
Additionally, what looked like the black,
corrosive substance from SCP-035 leaking onto
682 and melting away at the mask’s new host,
actually seemed to be another adjustment the
creature had made to its own physiology.
Instead of dissolving the Reptile, the substance
was being absorbed, diverted to a specially
formed gland inside the monster that was now
safely storing the corrosive goo within its
own mouth.
But further within, beneath all the external
and even internal changes occurring to SCP-682’s
body, a far greater change was taking place.
Deep in the recesses of the twisted, murderous
mind of SCP-682 was an intruder, a presence
that the Reptile could feel trying to bore
its way in, to not only make itself known,
but to take over.
The pair of them, the consciousnesses of both
these anomalies were battling each other for
supremacy, the Hard to Destroy Reptile wanting
to retain control of its own body and mind,
and the Possessive Mask desiring total dominion
over its newfound host.
SCP-682 had long been known to have a high
level of Psionic resistance, halting the spread
of SCP-035’s telepathic influence.
However, because the Reptile’s body had
adapted and acclimatized to the mask's corrosive
secretion, it meant 035 was able to persist,
hanging on and still trying to force its way
into the Reptile’s mind.
“You hate them all so much,” the voice
of SCP-035 echoed from inside the Hard to
Destroy Reptile’s head.
“Don’t bother,” it thought back in reply.
“You are alive.
That makes you as disgusting and putrid to
me as the rest of them.”
“But think what we could achieve… together,”
the mask whispered.
For a moment, the Reptile considered an alliance.
Both it and the mask possessed a shared hatred
towards humanity, although 682’s extended
to all other forms of life – including the
sentient comedy mask it now wore.
Though even a temporary cooperation between
the two might have its benefits, SCP-682 had
no intention of remaining bound with the Possessive
Mask for longer than it needed.
And in much the same vein, SCP-035 was only
proposing such a partnership to avoid being
removed from perhaps one of the few beings
that could wear it for an extended period
of time without being dissolved entirely.
Outside in the containment chamber, the Foundation
personnel had been instructed to remove SCP-035
from the Reptile, despite concerns that the
sudden removal of the mask would cause the
monster to enter a rage state.
The Possessive Mask was now fused with the
flesh of 682 thorough its specialized protrusion,
and the Foundation’s fear was the longer
that pair of anomalies stayed bonded, the
more the Hard to Destroy Reptile would be
able to adapt against other powerful SCPs.
So, Research Assistant Verheiden had been
ordered to increase the acid contents of the
tank to full capacity, hopefully burning the
tissue connecting the Reptile and the mask
to each other.
Before the white porcelain of SCP-035 could
slip under the rising acid, a clawed arm reached
up out of the boiling vat and pulled the Research
Assistant under.
Screaming, he landed in the tank with a splash,
followed by a rapid hiss.
Clambering up out of its containment tank,
the hybrid of SCP-682 and SCP-035 roared as
the combined creature freed itself from containment.
In the chamber below, all hell broke loose.
Security officers reached for their weapons,
not even waiting for the order before they
opened fire.
Bullets pinged off the porcelain comedy mask
that was embedded in the top of the Reptile’s
head, barely scratching the surface and unable
to pierce the monster’s scales.
Some guards charged in, only for Reptile to
spew a molten black substance from the specialized
glands in its mouth.
It was channeling the corrosive secretions
from SCP-035 into a weapon, the resulting
ooze dissolving the security team as they
approached, stopping their futile attempt
to re-contain it before they could even try.
Witnessing this, knowing their own imminent
deaths were near, researchers and remaining
Foundation security turned heel and ran for
their lives, as containment breach alarms
blared through the facility.
Although both anomalies were secretly intending
to betray one another, for now, SCP-682 and
SCP-035 were free to unleash their combined,
monstrous form on the humans they both hated
the most: their captors, the SCP Foundation.
Now go check out “WHAT IF SCP-343 WORE SCP-035?”
and “The Whole Story!
- What if SCP-096 Wore SCP-035?”
for more horrors of other anomalies wearing
the Possessive Mask!